oK we've got some big news relating to
YouTube sponsorship okay
very quick refresher YouTube has
released a new program in beta which is
called YouTube sponsorship they've
invited a hand-selected group of
channels where the david pakman show was
included people can sign up for YouTube
sponsorship for $4.99 a month by using
the blue sponsor button on our web site
on the YouTube channel and on the
YouTube video pages there's a lot of
really great benefits for YouTube
sponsors including sponsors only posts
and lots of other great things one of
the benefits is that there can be custom
emojis that are coded into our channel
only and that only our sponsors can use
and last week I said on the show we
don't have any I want some emojis but
we're not good at designing stuff I'm
not good at graphic design Pat's not
good at graphic design unless he's
keeping those skills a secret from me so
we said audience please help and the
great Korey topcase who did the original
Andy Warhol image that was part of our
2018 calendar and is also on our wall
here thanks to Pat has created some
great emojis which some of which we've
been able to add so now we're actually
putting these up on the screen
YouTube sponsors get to use emojis such
as TDPS hair which is a cartoon version
of when I did the crazy hair thing to
celebrate two thousand patrons TDPS
borscht which is an emoji of me with
Eastern European beet soup splash on my
face which once I did the entire show
with Pat choosing not to tell me it was
on my face because he thought it was a
pimple and he didn't want to embarrass
my clan it was borscht and others as
well a hatred themed emoji very very
exciting stuff and we can add more
emojis as we get more YouTube sponsors
also chat and comment badges are now
active if you are a YouTube sponsor you
will see that there are badges that will
show up next to your comments in chat
and on YouTube comments and right now
they are different colored versions of
the david pakman show logo and when you
get to the two-year mark you get it as a
badge
the picture of me with the wacked out
hair and you get a better badge the
longer you stay so new sponsors get one
badge when you get to a month two months
six months etc very very exciting we
also have as a YouTube sponsorship
benefit of sponsors only pole ok so
right now if you're a YouTube sponsor
this is only visible to sponsors you can
vote on which topic should we cover in
the upcoming pseudo-science miniseries
cleanses and detoxing right now winning
with chiropractic close behind followed
by numerology and pray or healing
another sponsor benefit this has nothing
to do with membership has nothing to do
with patreon it's a new initiative
YouTube only you can use the sponsor
button which you can find in a lot of
places on our channel and part of our
reducing advertising on the podcast and
reducing advertising on the broadcast
show which we announce that we're doing
is because of this initiative and we're
gonna keep doing more and my goal is 1%
YouTube sponsorship ok we've got four
hundred and sixty thousand subscribers
on YouTube if one percent signs up to
become a sponsor forty six hundred it is
a game-changer it changes the entire
financial picture of the show lock stock
and barrel we invite you in the audience
to be part of the good 1% that's what
we're calling it this is the good 1%
right it's not bad to be part of this 1%